What's like the common factor out of all of us here?
Gamers?
Yeah, but like what else?
What else do we all have in common?
Money?
But everybody has money in like some way or form.
Right.
So like that's not really a good comparison because that's like comparing us to chat.
Because we all have money.
But what makes us different from chat?
We're all like living, breathing.
Yeah, but chat's living and breathing.
Chat's living and breathing.
Yeah.
No, they're not.
Chat isn't real.
Oh shit, you're right.
Me and my zero viewers.
What the?
Okay, but like what else?
Like don't you have something that we also have?
No.
Don't you?
We have different things.
What do you mean?
Don't you have that, you know, that...
particularly adamant like...
thing in your...
folders?
I don't think so.
Don't you mean like...
I'm getting gassed right now.
Don't you mean like, you know, you know, did you have like a VTuber model?
Share for?
That you streamed?
Like, oh really?
Can you chat like pull up like clips of you using that?
Unfortunately...
Unfortunately, it's not Tuesday, so...
Oh, so you do have...
a...
VTuber model.
No, VTubers aren't real, so...
Then what's the Tuesday thing?
Yes, it's not Tuesday.
Yeah, but what is the Tuesday thing?
If VTubers aren't real?
I don't know.
What is it?
What...
Can you please elaborate?
What happens when Tuesday stays on Tuesday?
So if I ask you again on Tuesday, will you tell me what... would you say what it is?
No, I'd say, fuck you, bitch.
Also, anyway, I'm live now as well.
Are you live as well?
Share for?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm live as fuck.
Alright, so hello everybody!
Welcome to the Party Animals Twitch Rivals team!
We went straight into it with no introduction whatsoever.
Yippee!
Just like how...
We do our Twitch Rivals.
Anyway, this is my team.
Ditto, Surefour, and Bree.
Um, I honestly thought that like...
Some of them had Party Animals experience, as in like a lot of Party Animals experience.
That's why I recruited...
I have 7.3 hours.
7.3?
Did you do several tournaments?
You did like two Twitch Rivals tournaments.
No, not Twitch Rivals.
But you did two, like, Party Animals tournaments.
How much did you guys do?
I'm on the stock.
How... What did you guys do?
Team threw.
Oh.
It's teams.
Fuck.
So what's your placement?
I don't remember.
All I remember is the Murder Crumpets team had a mute that like played the game 24-7.
What the fuck?
They soloed the team.
They soloed... They like destroyed... So they destroyed... You got destroyed by a mute?
I didn't get destroyed.
You got... But you said destroyed the team.
Yeah, it's a team game.
Yeah, but so you're part of the team.
So you got destroyed.
Yeah, I lost with the team.
Yeah, so you got destroyed.
So you're not a god gamer.
Well, you know, there's percentages.
There's percentages.
Like, of effort in the team.
And what's your percentage?
I'm like 90.
You're like... Oh, you're 90% of the team.
Yeah.
So the mute destroyed 90% of the team.
Okay.
I'm so lost.
Yeah.
But if you're 90% of the team and the mute destroyed your team, you got destroyed by the mute.
Okay, listen.
I was like 60% of the team.
I was like 60 to 80 in the PAL world team.
Dude, I don't wanna be hearing this.
What do you mean?
In PAL world, we all did an equal contribution to the team.
I quote, sure for you have to carry us.
You're the carry.
Yeah, and you died to a fucking bug.
I can't... That can't be controlled.
All I'm saying is, if you didn't die to that bug, we could have got third place.
Yeah, well, maybe if you made me more pokeballs.
Oh yeah.
We made you a collection of pokeballs.
What do you mean?
I needed more of a collection.
You did not need... You did... It was not the PAL balls.
That was the issue here.
It was.
I had to clutch out with like minimum power balls.
I'd be Glorp'ing my shit bro.
Oh my god.
You what?
He was Glorp'ing his shit.
Oh okay yeah I just wanted to make sure I heard correctly.
Thank you.
You know Glorp?
Glorpnorphin?
No.
Yeah Glorp.
It's a little cat.
It's a little green cat with antennas.
Oh you're talking about the cast?
Thinking about that Spongebob rapper.
No I'm talking about Glorp.
Glorp?
What the fuck is Glorp?
There's Glorp.
Oh my god wait he's so cute!
Yeah he's Glorp'ing.
Oh.
Yeah he's Glorp if that makes sense.
Yeah.
There's you'll Lorp.
And there's... or Lorp.
Basically there's a color for every orb.
There's a color for every orb?
Wait what are the orbs?
Well there's like Glorp and that's blue.
And then what?
Lorp?
I have to look.
You have to look?
You don't know them by heart?
No I only have Glorp.
Glorp looks like a Neopet.
I love him.
Glorp.
Cat.
Basically the beginning letter is the color.
Oh!
Glorp is Glorp because it's green.
Is there Yorp?
Yorp?
There's no Yorp.
There's no yellow.
There's no yellow cat.
There's Blorp.
Is there Blorp?
There is a yellow one.
No there isn't.
There's Blorp.
I don't see any.
I think this is a myth.
I think only Glorp.
No.
It's real.
I only see Glorp.
There's no proof.
You only see what you want to see.
Wait then where the fuck is Yorp?
Where's Yorp?
I'm looking for him.
Yeah you can't find him.
No I can.
Where's Yorp?
Yeah he's gaslighting.
No I'm not.
Yeah I found him.
Here's Yalorp.
Where is it?
Posted in a team 3 chat.
My team 3 team don't give a fuck.
There we go.
I'm on it.
Wait there is Yorp!
Oh my god!
Wait how did you find Yorp?
My chat helped me.
Oh so you didn't do any of the work.
I got helpers.
So you didn't do any of the work.
Have you ever heard of a community?
Wait I thought chat wasn't real.
How are they helping you if chat isn't real?
You know like schizophrenics where they have voices in their head?
So the voices in your head help you.
Oh we're getting pinged for stuff now.
Okay nice.
Who are we?
It's match time.
It's time to find the lobby.
Please be careful.
Does this hide the code when we join it?
I have no idea.
I'm gonna fucking hide my game screen first.
Oh I joined a random game.
Okay custom game.
Custom game.
And then you search it up.
Okay.
Search.
What time is it over there for you?
Ditto.
Ditto what time is it?
10.
Oh it's 4 am.
Oh no.
She's locked in.
You usually sleep.
I can find it Bobby.
Maybe it's not up yet.
Oh no it's up.
I'm in it.
Oh I can see it.
I will join Dorky then.
Yeah join me.
I'm in.
Also it does show the code.
Oh Dorky you're in an online.
Oh I'll invite you in.
Let me see.
Okay.
Let's see where are you?
Oh I can't wait.
Give me a sec, let me see if I can invite you.
Oh, my friend.
Oh, I need to like, I need to add you in this...
Oh wait, no, I got you.
Okay, I sent you in.
Did you get it?
Are you Pussy Slayer?
Yeah.
Is that Pussy Slayer?
He's Pussy Slayer, but...
Oh my god, I'm not!
Alright, he's here to...
He's here to slay some cats!
I'm not thinking I'd be in Twitch Rivals.
It's okay, we're so locked in.
I was watching Drops Team fucking scrimming...
They were scrimming party animals.
For like two weeks.
Two to three weeks.
Why didn't you set up scrims?
Why did I not set up scrims?
Would you actually join scrims?
If I set it up?
Would you do those, Surefour?
Hehe.
Yeah, I'll take that as a fucking no.
I'm always down for scrims.
Yeah, I don't think you would fucking scrim party animals.
Yeah, I was watching fucking Drops with the full-on Apex roster...
Scrimming party animals and hard-comming.
It was actually crazy.
I was like, oh, I'm gonna go to the Apex.
Apex players are sweats.
Wait, what's the comparison between...
What about like Apex versus Overwatch?
Who's sweatier?
Apex?
I think...
I think Overwatch tries to be sweatier, but it just comes across more depressing.
Oh shit, is that true?
I don't talk to Overwatch anymore.
As an Overwatch player, I use Sweat.
Yeah.
We've gone through enough one tricks that never swap that we just become complacent with everything.
That's so true.
I'm so sorry.
I was the one trick, so you know...
Oh, ew.
You were the problem.
I was...
I was a Mercy main.
And I was a D.Va main.
Oh, you were part of the problem.
You were 100%.
I would've avoided you.
I would've avoided you and reported you.
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no.
Do you know what the game mode is?
It's Lollipop Factory.
Lollipop...
Yeah.
Okay.
So what are you...
I just know.
You collect it.
You have to like...
Yeah.
And then you have to move it to like a little tray and then you have to pull the lever to put the tray in.
And then there's like a big gummy bear that's worth like way more.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna be beating the shit out of them.
Okay.
So like what's the strat for this?
I remember when I tried to play this and I got absolutely destroyed.
You have people trying to stop them from putting in candy and then you have people on your team putting the candy.
And I'm gonna be interference.
Okay.
I'm just gonna be beating the shit.
I'll...
I'll help bring candy over.
Okay.
You gotta protect me.
You know and I will bring candy over.
I don't know what Bri is gonna do.
Okay.
Oh.
I will...
I will beat people up.
Okay.
Are you good at beating people up?
Yes.
Okay.
And you're not lying... lying to me like how you lied earlier, right?
I would never.
Okay.
I will protect you.
I'm indiscriminate in my beating.
Alright.
Wait.
No.
You're not supposed to beat us up.
You're part of the team.
Yeah.
Wait.
You guys are caught in the crossfire.
There's nothing I can do about it.
Then we lose.
You know what?
That's fair.
I thought you want to win.
Hey, listen.
If I have the lollipop stick...
This is party animals.
This is serious.
This is...
We just...
There's AOE.
You got to take it serious.
I'm serious.
But you're a gamer.
You should have...
That's why I'm saying.
I'm probably...
I'm forewarning at the beginning.
But you're a gamer.
You should be able to like, control the beatings.
No.
Listen.
I can't control the actions of my teammates.
I can only control myself.
I don't want to be a part of it.
I'm ready.
Yorp is just on my screen.
Oh, I'm ready.
Yorp Norpin?
Yeah, he's just Yorping.
Alright, here we go.
I believe in us.
We're so ready.
No, we got this.
It's okay.
Oh yeah, we're gonna win.
Alright.
Where am I?
Okay, here I am.
What you think, Yorp?
We have to go grab the candy!
The candy!
Let's go!
Beat him up, Trevor!
Beat him up, Bri!
I got a taser.
Okay!
Oh, they're going for the big one!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to pull... get the little ones.
Somebody beat up the big ones while I grab the little ones!
I'm grabbing it.
I'm hitting with the taser.
Wait, where's the...
Oh, they're getting the big one!
I'm punching them.
Okay.
Wait, where's the guys?
They're getting the big one?
I'm going.
Guys, I actually don't remember where the... where the...
The what?
Where is our area?
Oh, there it is.
We're red.
Okay.
Take the candy!
Okay, I'm grabbing...
I'm grabbing the mini candies.
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
Nice.
No!
It's okay.
Oh, he got the big one.
Pull it!
Wait, we got the big one?
He got it!
I got it!
I got the big one.
Nice.
Am I...
Oh, I can't pull it!
It can't be!
Guys, help!
It got me!
I can't pull it!
Somebody help me!
He's fucking punching me!
I need somebody to help me pull it!
I got it!
Nice work!
Big?
I've been punching the shit out of them over here.
Just keep getting the big one and we win.
Okay.
I had trouble fucking...
Okay, I need somebody to help me.
I need help!
Yes!
How do I get this down?
Wait, I don't think...
You have to go the long way.
You can't do it from the...
Up the ramp!
Guys, help me!
Liam's trying to pee pee!
Liam's trying to pee pee pee!
Liam's got me!
No, Liam!
I'm grabbing the small, one.
You guys go do your thing.
I'm grabbing the small one too.
You guys don't tip me!
I'm slowly handing over...
Oh, he's got the pan.
Oh no!
Liam!
Get off of me!
I'm here!
They're getting the big one!
We need to stop everyone getting the big one!
Okay, somebody fell in there.
I don't know who it was.
Guys, we need help.
They're about to get the big one!
I hope you guys are doing it!
I don't know how to play this game.
If you can just keep getting the small ones, it's fine.
We got them trapped in here.
No, don't, please!
I'm just a little dog!
I'm getting the small ones.
Please!
No!
Go, leave!
Run, run, Ditto!
He's on me!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm running.
Nice, nice.
I got it!
I'm just going!
They're bad?
Oh, you stole the big one?
Nice, nice.
Okay.
I'm getting crushed!
I got three of them down right here.
If you could steal it.
It's okay.
I'm getting out.
Just keep grabbing.
He's too busy on me!
I got him.
I got him sunlocked.
Oh my god!
It's okay!
I go put this on here.
I'm coming!
It's so lucky!
I can get the lever!
I got the big one!
Oh!
Oh my god!
We win!
Yeah!
Guys, I used the cooldown.
I used the cooldown.
I used the cooldown for a small one.
I didn't realize.
Just play it.
Pull the trigger.
Pull the trigger!
I'm trying!
I can't do well and I'm panicking!
I'm a diiiiiing!
Yippee!
We did
it!
Line of my resume bias!
Okay, sure.
But how much did Brie actually help?
I got pulled so many times.
They clutched out by stealing it while I was just fucking perma-knocking three of them on the ground.
Guys!
Yay!
Come on!
Do we do it again?
I don't know.
I thought it was only one.
Best of three?
Is it again?
Do we have to go through it again?
No, game two is buzzball.
Oh, I know buzzball.
What is buzzball?
Do we do it?
What?
That's the one where... I don't know.
Let's just play until something happens.
Yeah, let's just play until something happens.
Yeah, they're going for it!
They're going for it!
I'm going for the little ones.
Fuck this.
You guys can deal with that.
I know my place.
Punch him!
Nice!
Yippee!
Yay!
Okay, I'm pretty sure buzzball is the one where there's a ball and you have to throw it in the goal and if you hold it too long it explodes.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's like soccer.
Okay, I get it.
Yay!
I got a cow!
Got the avatar.
How do you clean?
I'm glad we're unlocking characters that we get for playing the game once.
It's okay.
I believe in... You know what?
After that first game, you know what?
I believe in us.
I didn't believe in us before we started, but now I believe in us.
Well, this one... If you get into that little thing at the end and you just press right click, it usually gets thrown in.
Okay.
Boom.
I'm using controller, so what's right click?
On the controller.
Oh.
I don't know.
I use keyboard and mouse.
Whatever your throw is.
If two people hold onto the ball, it explodes.
Oh, okay.
So we shouldn't hold...
Okay.
Well, you can.
Sometimes it's clutch.
I got it!
You got it!
Right click it!
Yay!
You just locked up and just fucking...
What?
What the hell just happened?
I did it!
So that's the throw button.
That's easy as...
No!
Oh, god.
Okay.
Alright.
Go!
Okay.
I knocked two.
You got it!
No!
No, no, no!
No, you got it!
Someone punched me out.
It wasn't me, I swear.
Oh, I know.
It was an enemy.
OH!
And the bats got it!
The bats got it!
I got knocked out.
No!
Punch it!
It's not fine!
Just hold on to it.
That's fine, that's fine.
No, it's not fine!
No!
It was in the end not fine.
We got the bad RNG.
I was hoping it would go to their side.
I hear you.
This time we got it.
I believe in us team.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
That's you.
Nice throw.
Come on, go pussy slayer!
No, pussy slayer!
I got knocked out.
I got knocked out too!
No, it was splinter!
No!
Splinter!
Okay, guys.
Now I don't have confidence anymore.
We're only down one.
It's like that's so fair.
Okay, I'll just run and grab it.
It's sixth.
I'm trying to grab him.
Oh, I grabbed him instead.
You got it, you got it!
Oh my god, it won't let me!
Okay, I'm just running again.
I'm just running.
No!
Please have mercy.
No, he knocked me out before I could get there!
I got knocked out!
Alright, winnable.
No!
I got knocked out!
Knocked out again!
It's up to you, pussy slayer!
I can't hit him!
Nice.
Nice pass.
Oh, I knocked him out.
Get it, get it.
I got it.
Throw it in.
Yes!
Woo!
Yay!
Now we're tied.
We did it.
We're doing it, guys!
We're doing it!
See?
Winnable.
It is!
Oh my god, it is winnable!
Winnable.
Who would've thought?
I got knocked out.
Oh, I got knocked out.
Oh my!
Oh god.
It's fine.
Get over here!
Okay.
I got him.
You're holding onto me!
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Oh, nice throw!
Nice throw.
Yeah, but he's heading over.
It's fine.
We got it near their goal.
Oh no!
He punched it away!
It's not near our goal anymore!
I'll wait for you.
I'll wait for the throw.
Oh god.
Wait.
I'm knocked out.
Oh, big knockout!
Big knockout.
I'm going over.
We'll throw it if you need to.
You got it!
Go, go, go!
We got it!
Yes!
Yay!
Only three more to go.
Oh my god.
It's not winnable.
Yeah.
Is it?
Pussy slayer with the goal.
Pussy slayer goal!
Got it.
Wait a minute.
Oh, nice.
Chipped!
Let's go!
I don't need practice.
Look at us.
Just do that every single time.
Just run it down mid every single time.
Just run it down!
I knew Tyler1 was right in some ways.
My philosophy.
Run it down.
Okay, never mind.
I'm out.
Oh no.
It's fine.
He fucked up.
Oh no.
Oh no!
He didn't fuck up!
You liar!
This will make the comeback better.
It's fine.
Instead of punching him, I just need to grab him.
Because the punch was missing.
Yeah, that's not good.
I just grabbed someone and I dragged him away.
Okay.
Run it down mid.
Run it down mid and then I'll fucking do this.
Let's go.
No, no, I'm out.
I'm out.
No!
You got me.
I'm out forever.
I missed everything.
No, I missed everything!
Oh, he fucked up.
He fucked up.
Oh no!
He didn't fuck up yet!
Oh!
Okay, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting.
Oh, I'm waiting.
I'm right here waiting for you.
Nice!
Oh my god.
Is this the next Messi right there?
Leon, no!
Goal!
Those moves!
Hey.
Alright, this is the last one.
Easy.
Come on.
Woah.
You got this.
I couldn't think you went in for me.
Oh god.
Oh no.
I'm waiting for you guys.
Knock the fuck out.
Oh, oh.
She needs help.
Do you need help?
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Good.
Oh, they're fucking... They're harassing me.
But I got it.
We won!
Oh my god.
Three people can't stop me!
That was four people.
Oh shit.
You're right.
Who needs to scrim?
We're just naturally talented.
What makes me gonna win?
Oh shit.
I'm out.
I can't even.
Oh wait.
No, they beat the photo.
I'm a winner.
Oh yeah!
Yay!
Is that automatically a win for us?
We don't have to play the third round, right?
Yeah, we won.
We won.
Oh my god.
What a speedrun.
Speedrun.
Alright, the next round two is Luggage Chaos, Beast Soccer, and Winter is Coming.
What's Luggage Chaos?
Luggage Chaos is the same thing as the candy one.
Only you have to put the luggage on conveyor belts and then they slowly go into a separate area that looks like a conveyor belt.
You can't drag the luggage into that area.
You have to parkour into it.
And then you grab the luggage off the conveyor belts.
Okay.
And then you put it in the candy and you just dump it down with the lever.
Oh, okay.
So it's just the lever stuff again.
Okay, so you...
It's just slightly confusing.
You can't just walk it to the dumping place.
You have to put it on the conveyor belt and then it goes through a little machine and then you grab it after.
I see.
It's the same thing.
You two are the punching people.
Didn't Ditto do that?
No, now we just put luggage on the conveyor belt.
Sweet.
We're doing it!
I can't believe I'm actually contributing this time.
Oh my god.
This is so different from my last Twitch Rivals.
Did you not do well?
I was not contributing.
Oh.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I still don't know what I'm doing, but like...
We're winning, so that's all that matters.
No, you're winning though.
Just constantly say that you do.
It's fine.
Is this Connor?
As in Connor...
His pants.
Oh my god!
Suck it!
I'm gonna beat you in the Tekken tournament too.
Unless he's on my team.
Still do it!
Still win!
Suck it!
You're gonna lose to me in Tekken 8 as well.
What is this conversation that you're having?
They're asking about their favorite swear words.
Chib asked me about my favorite swear word.
And then said, whoa.
Whoa.
What was it?
I thought it was bitch, right?
Your name is inappropriate.
I slayed cats.
It's a game about slaying animals.
It's just our team.
You're LARPing.
He likes Glorp.
Oh my god!
He loves Glorp too!
I play Destiny too.
How do you chat?
Oh, you enter.
What do you mean no I don't...
I don't.
If the streams are deleted, doesn't mean it never existed.
Like...
Did you stream it on Tuesdays?
I'm pretty sure that's a special day.
Oh yeah, that's a special Tuesday.
Yeah, I stream it on Tuesdays.
Every Tuesday.
Sunday is the only sacred day.
Why is Sunday a sacred day?
Because I don't play Overwatch.
Oh.
That's a variety day.
Wait, I thought Tuesday was a variety day.
What the fuck is Tuesday?
That's Wednesday.
Wednesday and Sunday.
Wait, then what's Tuesday?
We don't talk about it.
What's Tuesday?
Then is it Overwatch?
So you stream Overwatch with your VTuber?
No.
Then what the fuck is Tuesday?
Tuesday is whatever I want.
I don't know.
It's whatever I want it to be.
Yeah.
Valid, valid, valid.
I'm valid.
You're valid.
That's right.
You are.
Okay, well apparently we finished this so fast that we have to wait for the other games to be done.
We're just that good.
We're so good at this game.
Until we face the Apex team that's in this.
Wait, which team is that?
I don't know.
That is team...
It's DropStack.
It's Rogue's team.
Team 6.
That's the Apex team.
No, I think we can go against them.
I mean these are basically training rounds, you know?
Yeah, but it's gonna determine our seeding.
Oh.
So it's like the seeded matches.
Oh my god, seeds.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Ditto, are you awake?
Yeah.
He's not dead inside.
Ditto's just chilling.
He's vibing at 4 in the morning.
I haven't I haven't slept yet.
Oh my god.
I was playing on God's Star.
You were playing on God's Star?
Yeah, I just finished this main story.
Oh shit.
They had a concert and stuff too.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
It took me like 10 hours to finish the main story.
10 hours?
Yeah, yesterday.
Wait, how long have you been playing Honkai?
Today, yesterday.
Did you start yesterday?
No.
Maybe one month?
So it took like one month of like 5 plus hours of...
I started playing this game on the first day and I stopped playing it.
And I just came back.
How much money did you spend?
Ummm...
Don't count it.
It doesn't matter how much you spend the money on this game.
If it doesn't matter, then you would tell me how much you spend, right?
It doesn't matter if you have fun or not.
Oh yeah, okay.
So if it doesn't matter how much you spend, then you should be open to telling me how much you spend.
I can't remember.
You get it?
No, I agree.
I think you should actually to celebrate finishing it, I think you should spend even more money on it.
I think you should celebrate.
Just do more.
How many characters do you have on Honkai?
It's not that much because I just came back.
Ummm...
Maybe...
Let me...
Let me shake.
Let me open up Honkai real quick.
Wait, how many characters does Honkai even have?
I have...
37 characters.
Wait, out of how many?
Are you missing any character?
37.
Out of 37?
Wait, how do you know sure for it?
I don't know anything about Honkai's story.
Wait, do you even gotcha?
I only play gotcha games with PvP.
Yeah, like what?
Well, the last one I played was AFK Arena, I think.
AFK Arena?
Isn't that like a fucking YouTube ad sponsor game?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I see it everywhere.
I see it all on TikTok.
I played that shit like 7 years ago.
Wait, is that old?
It's existed for that long?
2018?
Holy shit.
Yes, sir.
I haven't played a gotcha game in a while.
The last gotcha game I played was Genshin because I was hella bored.
How do you think about Genshin?
Did you like it or did you stop because it was boring?
Yeah.
They made Ganyu, so they got that going for me.
They got Ganyu.
Listen, gotcha games...
I only play gotcha games for PvP because the whole point of gotcha games is supposed to be like buying Gucci wallets but for like weebs.
Yeah.
PvP roster.
I'm surprised you haven't tried out Miike.
Why the fuck would I play Miike?
Because it's FPS.
If I wanted to look at anime girl ass, I would look at something else.
Like what?
Like what then?
Yeah?
Yeah.
What do you say?
I think that's self-explanatory.
Wait, what do you say?
You know what that is?
What do you say?
That's a pin tie.
Oh.
I ain't playing no gotcha game for that.
That's not cool.
Alright chat, rate his taste.
Is it...
Wait, this is a few of the chat.
Like do you have any recommendations?
No, there's some good ones, but I'm not gonna say them out loud.
That's TOS.
Oh, yeah.
Pushing Slayer.
Pushing Slayer isn't TOS.
Yeah, but you say it out loud on Twitch instead of writing it down.
Is it really bannable?
Yeah.
Well, pay for your gotcha games for that.
They're similar.
Why would I pay for it when it's free on the internet?
That's true.
It's for the experience.
Hell no.
I want it to be a competition, okay?
You can make it competitive.
It's like, how you gonna make that competitive?
Chat can find a way.
Your chat can find a way.
Not my chat.
My chat is say-so.
Christian friendly.
Mine is full of intellectuals.
Yeah.
Are you dying?
Are you okay?
I'm sorry.
After hearing you say your chat is filled with intellectuals, I couldn't take you seriously anymore.
What the hell is that supposed to mean?
What the
hell is that supposed to mean?
Wait, there...
We have to ignore the bracket.
A mistake was made reporting a match.
Oh, wait.
Which one?
I don't even know what the bracket is.
Whose fricking line is there?
Whose bracket is it?
I mean, they can't really make a mistake with ours, because we just did something.
Yeah, ours was so clear cut.
Yeah.
You said your chat is like say-so.
Isn't that the whole thing?
Like not...
Like, what is say-so?
Like not lewd?
Yeah.
Hey, listen.
Anyone that says say-so, they're like...
It's like the Christianity of V2V.
They're like whole closeted freaks.
Whoa!
What is that supposed to mean?
It's like Christian girls, you know?
They're like freaks.
Whoa!
They promise their bodies to God.
Yeah.
And then they threw that away once they got a taste of the forbidden fruit.
Feels like you're speaking from experience.
Experience?
Oh my god.
When is our fucking...
When is our next bracket gonna start?
We did too good.
I know.
We won too quickly.
We're just too good.
Sorry, next time I'll try to play worse so we can be less bored.
No, no, no, no.
We gotta be faster next time.
I get it.
Next time we gotta be even faster.
We watched you walk into their goal in the first five seconds.
I don't think we can be faster.
We just couldn't register.
They couldn't register what I did there.
Oh, I like the fact that we have Pussy Slayer on the team so that as we do better and better we just have to constantly pay attention to the phrase Pussy Slayer as they talk about it.
I thrive on that.
Good.
I got AFK kicked from the lobby.
So I was on the tab for some reason.
Yeah.
I almost got AFK kicked.
I'm gonna use this time in a runescape actually.
You got a runescape?
Wait, what are you grinding for?
I'm getting my Warp Scepter right now so then I can clear barrows more efficiently.
Sweet.
Wait, what skill is that?
Well, Warp Scepter is for magic and then barrows is for barrows gear.
And then so you're trying to get better gear right now?
Yeah.
I'm getting mid gear for my Iron Man.
Oh, you're Iron Man-ing!
Oh!
That makes sense.
Oh my god.
He's multitasking just like a true Overwatch player.
While waiting in queue.
Yeah, he's maxing.
I forgot about how long it takes in between matches.
Yeah, that's why you have to start saying, like, start making jokes or something.
Oh yeah, help you.
Yeah, just commentary.
Help entertain your chat.
Brie, entertain my chat for me.
My chat's like sludge.
Ah!
Yeah, be funny for my chat, Brie.
This is your purpose now.
Ah!
What, uh, what, uh, what, uh, what, uh, what, uh, what, uh, what was the pirate's favorite letter?
What?
No, it's the pirate's favorite letter.
It's the C's, stupid!
He, ah!
Yes!
You just call me stupid?
What the?
If we, if you think you're so smart, what's 25 plus 25?
Uh, 72.
That's not that.
What?
It's not 72.
I said so confidently.
Why is it 72?
I don't know!
Where did the 72 come from?
Everything's falling apart.
Everything, oh no.
Our momentum is gone!
We lost our momentum!
No!
We were kicked!
We got kicked out, that means they're making the room, right?
No, you got AFK kicked, maybe.
No, no, they removed us.
Yeah, they did!
Yeah, they moved us.
We're fighting...
We're fighting Kendomerce now.
What did?
Yeah!
Finally!
Get off RuneScape!
Aw, yippee!
Get off RuneScape right now!
I'm getting to my tortoises and then I'll get off.
Let's see...
Typing in the Twitch rivals.
The Twitch rivals.
It's not showing up.
It showed up for me.
I spelled it wrong.
I just copied and pasted.
That's actually good.
I don't know why I'm typing them manually.
Okay, I'll just manually.
Ditto.
Okay.
I wonder if they won their last one.
Guys, did the Kendomerce team win their last round?
Stream sniped for me right now.
But like...
But not like unethically.
Unethically?
Ethically stream sniped just to tell me if they won their last game.
They did!
Wait, they did!
They're gamers!
They won their last match.
So they might be gamers.
Where the fuck is PussySlayer?
Oh yeah, he's still walking over.
PussySlayer alive.
The last man there.
Yeah, stream sniped respectfully guys.
Alright.
Kendomerce.
They're here to...
Did you guys win your last match?
Win your last match?
Oh, they did.
They did?
I know.
I just wanted them to...
I just wanted them to respond.
I know they did, so I want to see if they lied to me.
Oh no, I asked them immediately.
Oh, okay!
We did it.
We're bad.
We're making...
We're gonna make them think that we're really bad so they go easy on us.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
We got too old.
Okay,
we got it.
We have to make them underestimate us.
PussySlayer...
Make them pity us so that we can do better.
...was a huge...
It's okay, we can do this, guys.
We can do this.
What the fuck is this?
That's the...
I haven't played this one before.
Put the luggage on the conveyor belt in the middle and then it goes under those little...
like a little...
platform.
Yeah, you guys have to beat them up.
Yeah.
Yeah, so you and Tia are gonna beat them up as usual.
I'm just gonna beat the shit out of them.
Yeah.
They can go and take things from the conveyor belt in both the hub area and then our separate little area where we score points.
So like...
We gotta just keep it on.
Okay, so we'll figure this out, right?
We're gonna figure this out.
Yeah, I believe in you guys.
I'm just gonna punch shit.
Thank you.
That works, honestly.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, there's a golden case.
Yeah, it's worth a lot.
Yeah, somebody grab the golden case.
Oh, you grab...
Oh!
No, he got it!
Wait, he just ran into the thing.
I'm going into their spawn.
Wait, what color are we?
Are we red?
Okay, I'm going to red.
I'm trying to pull.
Guys, they're all pulling me.
I can't even bring the luggage over.
They're pulling me.
I'm out.
Guys, they're really good.
Yo, the gold briefcase is stuck.
I'm stuck under it.
I can't roll!
How do I get over?
Guys, how do I...
How do I get over this?
Oh, thank you!
Guys, how do I...
How do we get over...
Guys, I don't...
You can't get over if you have a suitcase in your hand.
Oh, wait, then...
You have to put it on the conveyor belt.
Oh!
Guys, I think they're winning.
Yeah, they are.
We were so...
No, I'm spawn camping them.
We're so confused about this game mode.
Okay.
I need help.
They're harassing me.
They're picking me up.
I can't get off.
This isn't going well.
Wait, we have too many people on their side.
You're taking it away from them!
You're taking it away from the goal!
Wait, I am.
Put it here and then put it under there.
I can't go.
I don't know.
They're harassing me right now.
I'm here.
Guys, they are putting a lot...
They are putting a lot on my end.
I figured out how to do this, but these guys are actually...
Okay, if you just hold it...
Yeah, I can't.
Oh, no!
I'm dead.
They trained!
They have a goal!
They actually know what to do.
No, you grabbed me!
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I grabbed the keys, though.
Okay.
Go to the lever!
It's fine!
I'm just doing it.
Please!
We're so new!
I said come closer to us!
Why are they being nice?
This isn't going well!
Oh, sorry.
That was a bad hit.
Oh, my God.
This is so hard.
They're so good!
I'm getting one man harassed!
They took my hat!
My beautiful hat!
Guys, this might be...
This might be a team.
That might win this.
Take it!
I fucked them up!
Oh, help!
Yeah!
I got him.
I dropped it.
We're good?
Oh, shit!
It knocked me out!
Wait, there's a taser gun on my head!
Oh, no!
I'm dying!
Guys, this might be a GG go next.
Okay, no, we gotta get a strat down.
It's fine.
This is Kyle.
This is definitely not our game.
Okay, the next one.
Guys, they definitely know we're bad now.
It's okay.
The next one is the soccer game.
We can do that.
Okay, I'll beat up the goalie.
That's my job.
I'll just beat up the goalie.
You guys do the other stuff.
That's just not our mode!
No, this is just...
Yeah, this wasn't it.
Guys, this is not the Apex Pro team that scrimmed every day.
Well, these guys have scrimmed.
They know what they're doing.
They have plans.
Maybe the Apex team was scrimming this team.
Honestly.
.
Round 2.
Fight.
Wait, are we playing a round 2?
No, I think we're just...
I think we're just waiting.
Instructions were definitely unclear for that game.
We can win this one though.
Oh, they're Minecraft?
That makes so much more sense.
They're what?
They're so coordinated.
Minecraft players are the god gamers of minigames.
They're just...
They're...
Oh my gosh.
I remember when I did Twitch Rivals in Fortnite and a Minecraft player won like top 5 or something.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
In the Fortnite fucking tournament.
This one I think we have to headbutt more.
How do we headbutt?
Or like we can headbutt?
I don't know.
Middle mouse button.
Okay, what is middle mouse button?
I don't know!
Instructions unclear.
Guys, that's okay.
We can lose like one round.
One matchup.
It's fine.
No, we can't lose.
Otherwise it'll seem like we're cheating.
We just did the... you know...
It'll make the story better.
That's true.
Oh, we're already going.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh, wait, wait.
Two of them are knocked out though.
Two of them are already knocked out.
I'm going to go...
I'm going over to beat up the goalie.
Oh no.
I got it out.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm beating up the goalie and I'm distracted.
Goalie for our team.
Guys, I'm distracting the goalie.
We can't hit each other.
Okay.
I got ball in midfield.
Guys, I got the goalie out.
I got the goalie out.
The goalie's out.
The goal.
We're trying to get the ball in mid.
Guys, I'm distracting the goalie.
That's good.
This goalie is so out now.
We're doing our part.
I'm doing my part.
Get out.
Oh no!
I hit the top limb!
The goalie was gone!
Listen, this ball is hard to control sometimes.
Oh my god.
That was a good hit too.
I'm really bad at Rocket League.
This is not...
Guys, this is literally a 3v3.
To be fair, this is a 3v3.
The goalie and I...
We're toughening it out right now.
Get out, goalie!
We're fine.
Oh shit.
It's okay.
The goalie and I are having our own slamdown.
I'm owning them.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
The goalie is out!
I didn't have enough stamina.
Oh, we rocked.
I knocked the goalie away.
He took away my aim!
I'm out.
I'm dead.
Get out!
This ball is hard to control.
They're like all rolling and stuff to go faster.
Yeah, you headbutt to roll.
Yeah.
I keep forgetting.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm out.
I'm out.
I'm out, but don't worry.
I'm gonna get that goalie out too.
That's fucking right.
You thought you could have it.
Chill.
That's fucking right.
How the do you roll in this game?
I don't know what it is for a controller.
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh, he knocked me out.
But that's okay.
He thought he could have it.
Good.
That's fucking right.
Get distracted by me.
No.
No!
What the...
Whoa!
That was like the...
I won my game.
Guys, I think if they score the next one it's over.
Oh...
What's going on?
Holy shit!
What the fuck am I watching?
Are you joking?
Maybe we need another one.
Maybe we need another player.
Wait.
Boo!
There you go, I did it.
You spent the entire game just finding someone in the corner and then instantly won.
It's just that easy, what can I say.
It's actually that fucking easy.
That's fucking right, Rabbit.
You thought I was done with you?
The goalie is distracted again!
You think I was done with you?
I'm dead.
They hit it the wrong way.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Don't worry, I'm the striker.
The little bear guy here, or the corgi, he's the one that sets up the combo.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh shit, guys, I don't know.
I'm gonna fucking beat up this guy though.
Okay, okay.
Oh no.
No!
I hit it midfield, I'm gonna midfield.
I'm rolling as well, I'm doing their strat.
Okay, I'm waiting for you guys.
No!
Okay.
Oh no, oh no, I'm waiting, I'm waiting for the fucking...
Ow.
Oh no!
You told me you blocked it with your body, thank you!
No!
Oh my god, that was so close!
Okay.
I hit it down, I hit it down mid.
I'm coming over.
I lost my hat!
No, I lost my hat!
No, my hat's blocking me!
My hat actually blocked me!
Oh, that's it, we're good.
The one time.
Oh, nice one.
The one time I didn't distract the goalie.
Oh no, okay, it's still over here.
It's okay.
The one time I knew I should never left my post.
You thought you could get away from me.
Okay.
Okay, she did get away from me.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
The goalie's gone!
Quick!
We need to get the ball over there.
Yes,
nice!
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's a goalie there, Doki!
I feel like I have to play defense.
I'm scared.
The goalie's gone back up!
I didn't want you guys to go there while I distract the goalie!
The problem is, I need to play defense.
I can't play defense and offense at the same time!
That's what midfield is!
Midfield is G in offense!
That's the name for midfield!
If I go full offense then...
Oh, wait.
Alright, I'm going on the offense.
Alright.
Okay.
What the?
It's back.
Oh my god.
Okay, alright.
You go offense.
I'll do mid.
Okay.
I can't punch.
Oh my god.
I ran out of stamina!
Jumping and kicking into it is very good.
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
Wait, I thought you were fucking offense.
What happened?
I'm just trying to do what I think will be the best right now.
Look at that.
Look at that edge.
Yeah, but there's no offense!
There's no offense!
I'm scared if I'm not over there, the ball's going to go into the goal.
Oh, big pass.
There it is!
There you go!
You're offense, Joe!
This is your job!
Yeah, well, unfortunately, I pass in mid.
Oh my god!
You're passing!
Okay.
I'm going in.
I'm going out.
You know how soccer works?
It involves passing!
I thought you were offense!
Fucking offense!
I can't solo Ronaldo this!
I thought you were Messi!
What happened?
I saw...
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Watch your part!
What is this?
I have three on me!
We have a minute!
I'm trying!
I got it, I got it.
Oh my god!
All I'm saying is I would have scored.
Nice block.
Bullshit.
Bullshit!
Nice!
We definitely will lose!
I did score though!
I gave us our one point!
Hey, I set up that score.
I set up that score.
Oh, you did a good job.
Thank you!
I jump kicked into it at the start.
It's just so sad.
It just wasn't for us.
This was not our round.
We were against Minecraft players.
If this was banjo ball, they would have been shit on.
What?
I'm sorry.
What the fuck is banjo ball?
It's a Warcraft 3 custom game.
You should set up a Warcraft 3 Twitch Rivals and then invite them back for a rematch.
I've been saying that.
Wait, why can't you do it?
I'm not a setup guy.
You're not a setup guy?
No.
Basically, I'm like a side character main character.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but like Twitch Rivals is like really easy though to set up.
Cause like Twitch does most of the work.
Nah, then I would have to like message someone.
That's out of my pay grade.
They come to you.
I'd rather play RuneScape.
Has there ever been a RuneScape Twitch Rivals?
Uh, they've had like Deadman modes and shit.
What's Deadman mode?
I don't know.
It's like basically where you play RuneScape normally.
But you have insane XP rates and if you die once, you're out of the tournament.
Oh shit.
It's basically like a giant battle royale.
But the entire RuneScape map.
Wait, were you part of it or?
Hell no.
I know, it seems- why not?
I thought you loved RuneScape.
I'm not that autistic.
But you are on the spectrum though.
Cause I remember you took the test.
Hell no.
Yes you did.
You took the test.
Listen, every time I've gone to a psychologist, they've said I'm normal.
I don't know what to tell you.
Yes but you took the test.
It's okay, are you saying that an internet test is better?
It was a really good internet test though.
It was like a couple of pages long.
They were trying to make me take the test and I was like, I'm scared of knowing what I am.
It said I might be.
Oh.
Wait, do you remember the number?
Uh, there's a different- in one Discord I'm in, we make sure everyone takes the test and then we put the number beside their name of the test.
That's really funny.
What's the number?
I was a 28, but if I answer the question like I'm able to imagine things, I was a 6.
What does that mean?
I can't imagine things.
I was a- Oh yeah, yeah, I remember you had an amputation.
Yeah, yeah.
I was a- I was a- I was a 169.
That's a different test.
I'm thinking it went that high.
Oh, okay.
Is that- wait, wait.
Higher is more...
It's more- Oh!
More flavor.
More flavor?
Yeah.
Just a more, I guess like a more delicious type.
That's what that- Yeah.
Autism is tasty.
Yummy.
Apparently there's one more in game they have to wait to finish.
And then- That we weren't the slowest?
That was like the world's longest match.
That was the longest soccer match ever though.
It wasn't that long.
Actually, to be fair, we did lose really quickly.
And then the last one was just long.
Okay, the luggage one was- yeah.
That was a disaster.
The luggage one was- yeah, that was a- accidentally like- I was like, took some of our briefcases to the end.
Oh my god.
I was confused.
The instructions were so unclear.
You'll get it next time.
It's okay, if they put that in that- if they put another round of that in there, it'll be easy.
We'll know what we do.
We have a system.
We'll be- we're gonna be a- It's okay.
So ready for the next round.
I'm almost ready.
What is the third game?
The third round is team score into the game.
What's into the game?
Oh, is that the arcade?
No, we're doing Winter is Coming.
No, that's round two.
Oh.
Are we still on round... oh, wait, no.
We're on round three.
We lost two.
Into the game.
Yeah, so...
Am I allowed to Google it?
Am I Google that?
That's the arcade one.
Yeah, the arcade.
Eww.
Oh my god.
So we need someone that's dedicated and going into the game.
I can do that.
Oh, wait.
We can also... I found out that if you take their arcade machine, you can go to the bombs yourself and make them lose scores.
Oh.
Yeah, but I feel like that's a waste because then you're just going to get punched out.
That's true.
Or do you still get the shield when you go into this?
Yeah, you get the shield though.
So like, it's worth the risk to make them lose points.
Yeah, and you're wasting time.
Yeah.
So like, I feel like if you knock them out, you go to...
Oh, Team Doki, feel free to leave the lobby.
Oh, they want us to leave.
Okay.
Why do we have to leave?
Okay, I guess we lost.
Because we're the freaking losers.
Yeah, this is... we're the losers.
We have to leave.
For every winner, there is a loser.
I thought we were going to win.
Um...
I thought...
Why did Luigi win?
Oh my gosh.
You know like, when they did the year of Luigi, like Nintendo ended up losing so much money for that.
So they never give Luigi anything ever again.
Really?
Yeah.
I guess people were like, oh...
It was like their worst financial year ever.
That's the damn problem with these corpos.
They just look at the finances and not the lives of other characters.
Their goddamn shareholders and stockholders got them by the britches.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
It's not about the money.
Luigi didn't deserve this.
I got my Warp Scepter.
Oh yeah, high five Rush.
That was so sad.
When I...
The...
The company...
High five Rush.
The company closed down.
I'll remember you always.
That was so sad.
How the hell do I charge this thing?
Charge what?
My Warp Scepter that I got as a drop from...
Warp Scepter?
That's what your company's game is.
Yeah.
An XP map.
I'm XP maxing right now.
Wait, that's true.
I should go do my dailies.
Wait, not on RuneScape, but...
Yeah.
Did I...
Are you doing your dailies?
Did you do your Honkai...
Honkai dailies?
Yeah.
Did you do your...
I'm...
I'm doing it right now.
You're doing it right now.
See?
We're all XP maxing right now.
Am I the only one just relaxing, just chilling?
Hey, I...
I have the ability to multitask, so...
I'm not the only one.
That's a lie.
Multitasking isn't real.
I'm literally doing it right now.
That's a lie.
I'm talking, I'm streaming, I'm RuneScaping, I'm in Twitch Rivals tournament.
Yeah, but then you're like using less of your...
I'm looking at Twitter, I'm alt-tabbing, I'm going left, I'm going right.
Yeah, but then you're putting like 20% of effort on each of it.
Drinking my Coke Zero.
So you're not putting 100% effort.
Yeah, but RuneScape is very AFK-able.
Yeah, but then you're doing all these other stuff too at once.
So you're splitting your mind.
Yeah, but I don't need...
You're splitting your mind.
So it's not like actual min-maxing.
You're min-minning.
No, I'm max-minning.
Oh, we got it.
Okay, wait.
You're min-minning.
Oh yeah, the lobby's up by the way.
Did this team win their last game?
Did Joe Bartolozzi won their last game, chat?
No.
He did it, they lost.
Wait, Joe Bartolozzi?
That's the TikToker.
He's a TikToker?
Who's he?
He's a TikToker.
Yeah.
Wait, what does...
He TikTokes.
What TikTok does he do?
He screams.
He screams?
Yeah.
Wait, how many followers does he have?
A lot.
Joe...
Yeah, I think a lot.
Bart.
Is he an actual real guy?
Oh my god, he is a real guy.
Wait, wait.
You think he's fake or something?
What does that mean?
Holy shit, he has 24 million followers?
What the fuck does he do?
He TikToks.
Oh my god, what is TikToks like?
He screams.
Yeah, that's it.
That's good to know.
All right, I'm gonna watch this.
Okay, I'm actually curious.
What is this TikTok?
Oh,
he's a reactor.
Yeah, he screams.
That's it?
That's how he reacts?
Wait, where's my 24 million followers?
I scream all the time.
3, 1, 2, 0.
No, we lost.
We lost.
We are...
We are very bad.
Cookie, watch me.
Oh, I did.
I did invite you.
Okay, I'll do my union.
Sorry to break it to you, Pucko.
Bro, he's a party animal streamer...
That is...
I'm sorry.
What?
That you have to do this.
He tells me to win if you get kicked off.
Wait.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
We're ready.
Alright, into the game.
Okay, I'll work on doing...
Wait, who's defending and who's...
I'm just gonna beat the shit out of them.
Okay, but are you defending beating the shit out of them or offense beating the shit out of them?
Offense.
Offense?
Okay, I'll go with Shore 4 and then Bri and Ditto go defense.
Okay.
I'll focus on Arcane.
Alright, we got this.
Arcane?
League of Legends?
Oh my god.
Season 3?
Oh, the misery.
Everybody wants to be my enemy.
Woo!
Are we ready?
Cat chest.
Weddy.
I don't know if I wrote ready yet.
Okay, apparently they lost their last game too.
So like, whoever loses this one is the biggest loser.
Yeah.
Guys.
I don't know if I can handle losing again.
What will happen if you lose, Shore 4?
What will you do?
The night sky gets angry.
Even the devil shudders.
Guys, we don't want Shore 4 to lose again.
We don't know what he's gonna be like after.
There's still two teams below you.
Yes, because we're 1-1.
Wait, that means there's a team that lost every game.
What?
That's not us though because we had our one already.
We're so ready.
Maybe it was the people that we went against.
The first time.
And maybe we...
They were just not good at the game.
And we got false help.
Look, look.
This team is...
This team is a bunch of TikTokers.
Actually, I don't know.
But like...
Yeah, I only know one TikTok.
We're just a bunch of VTubers.
So like...
I'm not.
I'm normal.
Sure you are.
Oh, this one is so hard.
Yeah, yeah.
You're a defense.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
We got this.
All right.
It's fine.
I will beat everyone up.
Wait, one of them is an actual Minecraft player on Joe's team?
What?
Oh no.
It's over.
Why?
They have a minecrafter.
It's over.
Minecraft speed one.
No.
Okay.
I'm fucking going in.
I'm going in.
We're blue.
Oh my god.
Ow!
You fucking punched me.
I thought you were going in the machine.
I'm trying.
No!
I'm in it.
I got to go down.
Wait.
I thought you were going in ours.
Who's going in ours?
No.
I'm doing offense with you.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
And then I'm picking the arcade when I do.
We need people on our machines.
All right.
We're going in.
Okay.
I'm getting in.
All right.
You get involved.
You got it.
Wait.
Oh my god.
We need to stop them though.
Oh god.
Wait.
Who's getting in ours?
Who's supposed to be getting in ours?
I don't know, but I'm...
I think that was Doki.
No.
Wait.
I said I'm doing offense.
I'm doing offense and I'm doing bears.
That's what I meant.
I'm punching.
You got it.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
I'm trying to grab it so I can get onto the bomb.
Please.
I'm trying.
You got it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm grabbing.
I got it.
Wait.
Where am I?
What?
Oh my god.
They knocked me out.
I punched him out.
We got a bunch.
Why would it grab the fucking stick?
I got it.
I'm trying to fucking get to the bomb.
Give me the bomb.
You go.
I'm trying.
I punched him.
I'm trying to grab.
You go.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait.
They're going in ours.
Punch him out.
They got me out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Give me.
I'm gone.
I'm on it.
I'm passed out.
Okay, we're all passed out.
Wait, you guys haven't grabbed anything.
We're trying, okay?
Nooo!
They got it!
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
That was my bad.
You got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
No!
I'm out, I'm out!
Oh my god, he...
They're so good!
These are mine right there!
I got some points.
Nice.
I'm trying to grab...
Grab me the machine, not the stick!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, when you're on it, they can knock you out.
I noticed that.
You don't have a shield when you're on it.
Nice.
Guys, I think it's over.
Oh, when you're on the enemies.
I think it's over.
No, we got it.
Keep fighting!
I think it's over.
I'm trying, but...
I knocked him out, grabbed the stick.
I'm trying, I knocked out two.
No, he got it!
Nooo!
We got it!
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Okay, I'm trying to knock them out!
Tripper, are you knocking them out?
Of course I am!
I got the bomb!
I spotted it with the bomb!
My points!
Nooo!
They got it!
Cheebar.
It's okay, we have the second round.
Guys, we have the second round.
Look, they have a Minecrafter.
Yeah.
What's the second round?
The second round is... It's Beast Hockey!
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Okay, the hockey... That has ice.
Okay, I'm really... Lemonade my neck with dripping.
All I'm gonna do is I'm gonna beat up the goalie.
That's all I'm gonna do.
I'm just here to beat up the goalie.
Oh my god, don't be!
That's supposed to be my...
That's supposed to be my strat.
Wait, no you don't.
You're the one to score!
Well, usually when I play these, I only try and grief the enemy team.
Okay, okay.
But like, are you good at scoring though?
I don't know.
Wait, I'm gonna beat up the goalie and then I'm gonna... I'm gonna steal the shield.
I'll try my best.
I'm gonna steal this shield after.
Wait, that's... dank dank.
It's okay.
Doki, but you're Canadian.
Look, I have very limited knowledge on hockey.
Other than...
the Canucks team.
I played a lot of hockey when I was younger.
Wait!
Yeah, you're Canadian too!
Sure for it!
You should be the scorer!
I say you're...
I played right side defense when I played hockey.
Oh yeah, today you're gonna be offense today.
I'm offensive.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm going in.
I'm going in to steal it.
Wait, wait!
I got it out.
I'm distracting the goalie!
This is your time!
I stole the canuck!
Sure for it.
What the fuck you want from me?
I literally saved us and then I got knocked out!
What am I supposed to do here?
All I'm saying is you were the...
You had the Canadian buff.
Listen, it's not just me.
Remember, 80%...
Who's our goalie?
It's not me!
I'm out!
I'm fucking stealing your shield.
Oh no!
We have no goalie!
Oh my offense!
Oh my goalie!
Look!
There's no one there!
The enemy team picked up our shield that they're supposed to use.
I said I wasn't goalie.
Yes!
Get it in!
I'm knocked out!
I'm knocked out.
I'm out.
I'm out cold.
I'm fucking dead.
Nice!
Nice.
Winnable.
Yippee!
You idiot!
See, you say I'm offense, but we got 2 on the offensive side.
So I have to play defense!
Wait, we can have 2 off- offense.
But then we have no defense.
Oh, wait!
What about the other girls?
What are you trying to say about the other girls?
All I'm saying is I'm the flex right now.
Okay, look.
I'm getting rid of the goalie right now.
Look, I'm getting rid of the goalie.
The goalie got rid of me though.
I punched him.
Okay, I'm trying to...
I'm just punching them all out.
They stole our shield.
I got the shield!
I'm coming back for you guys!
Oh my god!
I got the shield for you too!
Uh oh.
Why are you being stealing?
Ping diff.
I hit you.
Ow.
It's okay.
I'm getting my wood.
This guy is a minecrafter right there.
What's going on?
They grabbed our shield.
They grabbed your shield?
Nice!
Grab the shield back!
It's okay.
I got the shield!
They got the shield back.
I knocked that bit out.
Okay.
Yeah, you can tell this guy is a party animal player.
Ow!
Oh, I died!
I knocked him out!
Nice!
I got the goalie!
And I got the shield!
Nice!
What is happening to this puff?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Nice!
Okay.
They are in there for sure.
Oh, I jumped.
Yes!
Guys, this is not looking so good.
No, no, no, no, this is our comeback.
This is our comeback.
It's good.
It's winnable.
Okay.
Okay, I'm coming in to actually help.
For real.
Okay!
Yeah, for real this time!
For real, I'm actually you.
I shall assist.
Okay.
I shall use my Canadian debuff.
That's it, Jill Bart.
You've knocked me out too many times.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Yurius now.
I'm heading over, what do you want me to do?
I'm literally here!
You- Oh no!
No!
Nice one!
You hit me twice!
I set that up for you man.
Yeah, and I knocked out two of them mufuckas.
Okay, I'm waiting for the pass.
Oh, not that middle.
Yes.
Oh no!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, I almost knocked you out.
Oh, he's- Nice!
Nice!
It's a party animal.
Guys, I got some bad news.
They only need one more.
Oh guys, guys, surely, surely we can come back.
It's a comeback right here, right?
Okay, this is getting hard bullying though.
It's a comeback, it's a comeback.
It's so wittable.
It's the comeback of the century.
This is it.
Punch me in the chin.
Oh shit, our goalie's down.
Our goalie's down.
Okay.
Oh, I'm down!
This is just a round robin.
We're not last because we won our one game.
That's all that matters.
That's true, we're not last.
We're not last.
Does that mean we progress or are we out?
No, we have- this was a round robin so then we have seeded after this.
Then it's like single- We're just gonna be seeded with the losers.
That's like single elimination, I think.
It's single elimination after this.
Which is good!
We purposely lost so we can get easier games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's not- Madoki, I have some bad news for you.
That's not how seeding works.
If you're last, that means you go against- that means you go against top seed, which means you go against the hardest of them.
No, that's not how that works.
There's no way.
No, no.
Where did you get those rules?
Who told you that?
I was your pro player.
Who told you- you were a pro player.
I played professional video games.
You were a pro player, but times have changed.
Times have not changed.
Maybe in the VTuber world, but this is the Twitch Rivals.
Times have changed.
This is the Twitch Rivals.
It's not VTuber exclusive.
Okay, but like, why would they put us in the- Why would they put us in the harder queues when we're losing?
Wake up to reality.
Everything goes right in this accursed world.
No, but things are supposed to go right!
It's supposed to be our world!
Crying emoji.
Okay.
How is the seeding?
Okay, second stage.
Single elimination.
Best of three games.
First to three points.
Oh, it's first to three points.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but it doesn't even tell- Oh!
Is this just beat-em-up?
Or quarterfinals?
Conveyor, trebuchet, wind tunnel.
Oh, no.
What's conveyor?
Oh, god, wait.
What is conveyor?
Shrug.
What is conveyor, guys?
What is this?
Oh, it's a big conveyor.
Yeah, but is it like PvP?
Yeah, Last Stand is like PvP.
You have to dump people off.
Um, like there's a bunch of weapons that spawn in.
And then you pick them up and then you dump them off the side.
Oh!
Okay.
So, hopefully this should be good.
Yeah.
Because it's just beating people up.
Yeah, yeah, hopefully that'll be easy, right?
Yeah.
I love beating people up.
See, that's good.
I'm buying earth runes right now.
Hopefully.
We got this.
You're min-mining again?
Yeah.
Okay, back to my dailies.
Back to your dailies?
Free entertain us!
I'm playing Neopets!
Entertain us!
I got more core stuff to do!
People still play Neopets?
Yeah, they like recently uh, they recently sold Neopets to uh, some tech guy who is like a Neopets fan.
Yeah.
And then they're rebuilding.
Yeah, they're rebuilding the uh, they're rebuilding the...
Does it still look like it was made in 2001?
No, it's...
Oh, okay.
It looks like it was made in like 2012.
Huh.
They upgraded it a little bit.
I know like, I know they're trying to do like something uh, I know they're trying to do like some updates to it.
And adding new game modes.
Yeah, no they're doing a lot.
Like they're doing events and stuff finally.
And they brought back unconverted pets.
Which is amazing.
Oh yeah, I remember that!
Yeah.
I remember that.
Because they sent like a fucking newsletter out to everybody about it.
Yeah!
I'm autistic enough that I cried when they brought back unconverted pets.
Yeah, because then you can like, you people were like selling it for like crazy amount of real money.
It was like hundreds of dollars.
If you could get a Pokemon, or a Pokemon, a Neopet with like a good name, it was genuinely hundreds of dollars.
It was like, yeah, and I remember like you can actually buy like real Neopoints and like real paintbrushes like and stuff with real fucking money.
Yeah.
Wait, did you actually cry?
Yeah, no, because I'm autistic.
That wasn't a joke.
I was just, you know, you know.
I got a fairy sweet talk.
Little like seven year old Brie was really happy, okay?
I was living a really good life.
Yeah, I miss Neopets.
I used to like grind that game as if it was a fucking job.
Dude, same.
When I was like really young.
Because like that was my life.
Oh yeah, when I was young too.
I did Neopet dailies.
Just like how people today do Genshin dailies.
And Honkai dailies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did that when I was a child.
And there was like a website called SunnyNeo or something.
SunnyNeo!
And they would have like a checklist of like here's some stuff you have to do every day.
And then I would click every link every day to make sure I get my dailies done.
Yeah, yeah.
Neopets was my gacha.
Yes, but it was free.
The only time I was spending was, the only thing I was spending was my time.
Time is...
Time is money.
I was not spending actual money.
I didn't get scammed into doing the whole, what was it?
The Neopets exclusive shit.
Doki is just hurting my feelings right now.
Neopets premium?
Yeah, imagine spending money on Neopets premium.
I didn't spend real money on that.
That's wild.
Imagine spending money on this game.
Imagine spending money on Neomall and Neopets premium for the super wizard just cause you wanted to like search up the lowest prices.
Yeah.
It's not worth your time.
That's crazy.
Is it?
I don't know what the hell is going on.
Doki is hurting my feelings and making fun of my spending choices.
That's what's happening.
That's sick.
Oh my god.
Look I got priorities okay.
My priorities are very stupid.
Oh my god.
You know like when we were fighting at Joe's team a bunch of his... I don't know if it was happening in your chat but a bunch of his chatters came to my chat just to like cheer for Joe.
Really?
That's funny.
What supportive guys.
And then when we lost we were like Yeah!
Joe's better!
And I was like what the fuck?
Happy little guys.
Got to tone down that happiness there to their own chat.
Chat hoppers.
Yeah.
Preview!
That's true.
It's not showing up with the map.
What?
What do you mean?
The new game.
It's not showing up.
New game?
Oh the quarter finals?
Oh shit the quarter finals!
Yeah!
Quarter finals!
Who played against these people?
ZuriSparks.
No they're all new people.
Nice.
Alright if we lose this we're out.
Just so you guys know.
It is life or death for real.
It feels so good.
It's life or death.
Right here.
Wait it is not showing up.
Yeah it's not.
I thought you were lying.
Why would I be lying?
I thought you were lying about this.
Compulsive liar.
I know because you're about your resume.
I'm sorry.
You saw that first round.
I carried at least two things to the end.
Did we see that second and third round?
I think that was it.
I'm just being held back.
You're being held back by who?
Name names right now!
Who is it?
I don't really want to.
Not to cause any drama.
But I'm just saying that I'm not being let let you know show my true skill in this game.
Um...
Why is it not showing up?
I wanna join.
I wanna be part.
Still not created yet.
Oh...
We... okay team Squeaks and team Joe are against each other.
So if we win this we might have to go against Joe again.
Joe?
Joe Mama.
Okay.
That's weird.
I haven't seen it yet.
Alright somebody send this guy a friend ID.
And I will invite you.
And then Bri you...
You give your friend ID there.
And then invite us.
Okay.
Copy.
Oh apparently the room is not showable.
So like they have to invite us individually with the friend ID.
What the?
So we just gotta wait.
Just gotta wait.
The first one to die is Deadweight.
All right everyone makes sure Doki dies last.
What?
I'm the captain I can't be Deadweight!
Captains are usually the Deadweight.
I literally Scored.
I was the only person that Scored.
I'm a charismatic person to bring people together, not to actually do anything.
It's like a CEO.
Okay, okay, but I actually did stuff.
Keep telling yourself that.
Oh yeah, the first game, the first game, I scored almost all the goals in the first game.
And who set up those scores?
The second game, I scored the only goal in the second game.
That was luck.
I also kicked it forward.
I knocked two people out.
Game three, I set up the goal for you.
I knocked two people out before you set it up.
See, this is the self-centered thinking we're talking about here.
This is team games, but you're only thinking about what you do.
Yeah, but you're self-centered as well because you were telling people that you did all that stuff as well.
You told us that you were 80% of the team last which round.
I'm just saying, my piece of the story.
My story matters.
What is this friend ID?
It's in your fucking profile.
In Party Atlas.
Oh!
Are they just waiting for us?
Where are you?
Where is this room?
So am I.
What do they want?
It's in the...
Calm down, try again.
Oh god, I've been searching for you.
I've been searching for you for too long.
You told me to calm down.
What the...
Do I just like...
add someone to like...
wait to get invited?
Yeah, we have to like...
We have to wait for Bri to get in and then she's gonna invite us in a vid...
She's gonna invite me and then I'll invite you too.
Okay.
Okay, accept.
Woah!
Okay.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Oh wait.
Do I have to add you guys?
Oh no.
Guys.
Just add me.
Did you add me?
I did it on Party Animals.
I did it.
Yo, one new game friend?
I said that.
I have friends.
Thank you.
Yay!
Okay, I sent a new mic to everyone.
Okay.
I'm here to slay.
Where should we slot?
Yeah, the last... it's the beat up.
Oh, okay.
It's a beat em up.
How come we couldn't find this lobby?
Like, what the fuck?
I don't know.
Oh, it's because you didn't put the space dash.
Oh!
That makes sense.
I just clicked the R and I couldn't find it.
I literally copied and pasted this.
So that's why I'm there.
Well yeah, because in the copy paste it was...
Okay.
There's no space bar.
Oh!
Okay, so all we do is beat em up.
And then throw them out.
Are you guys gonna throw things?
Yeah.
I'm going on the sauce.
Alright.
Whoever dies first is a dead weight.
I'm knocking Doki Bird out.
What?!
How could you do this to the captain?
How could you do this?
I can't believe you've done this.
I can't believe it.
We're a team.
I got a bomb.
That's not cool.
Oh my god.
I didn't get anybody.
Get up!
Wait.
I'm good.
How do I get up?
Wait.
How do I?
Oh, it's so hard when you're on the side.
I don't know how to get up this.
Okay.
It's up to you guys.
I'm out.
Oh my Doki!
Wait.
Were you the first one out?
No.
Ditto was.
Me.
No.
I got my one.
I thought Ditto would fucking walk off the conveyor.
Okay.
I'm alive.
No.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Did she not?
Did that happen?
Okay.
Wait.
I'm throwing bombs.
I'm throwing bombs for you guys.
Uh oh.
Never mind.
I might be dead.
Oh no.
No.
This is the end.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Guys.
You're okay.
I'm dead.
No.
Free.
This is it.
This is on you.
This is.
It's only me.
This is all on you.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh no.
I throw a banana.
That was their one.
I entirely missed.
Free.
I'm scared.
No.
Uh oh.
Save me.
No.
No shot.
What happened.
What happened shrimpfire.
This is your game.
Honestly.
This iscaped it.
Wait.
You're done for.
Yeah, this is pinged it.
Oh, I fell off!
Alright guys, it's up to you.
Good luck.
Guys...
When I heard I fell off and I'm the only one here now, I'm scared.
No, you got Ditto.
Ditto's there.
Oh, Ditto, you're still alive?
Oh my gosh!
Ditto, are you still alive?
Yeah.
I don't know how to jump off this one.
What do you mean?
He just had to keep jumping.
Oh, not that way!
That's all!
Now you're the only one.
Okay, now I'm still here.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
Now you're the only one.
They're all coming after me!
Hey, freaking kill them.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Bumba.
Oh, yup.
You just gotta put in the fucking montage.
Oh my gosh.
This is the comeback.
I got knocked out instantly.
I don't know, guys.
You just pushed me!
I would take one guy with me.
You took one guy with you?
Hell yeah!
Guys, I can't get back up.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try and kill him and then I'm gonna take him down with me as well.
Yeah, me too.
That's my plan now.
No!
Oh my god, he's growing!
He has the spinach!
He has the spinach.
I'm a little scared.
Oh.
Jump.
Oh no!
I heal you.
Help me!
Thank you!
My hero academia.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I'm trying to get back up.
How do you get back up?
Oh, there you go.
Guys, I'm struggling!
If you jump kick, I think it's more of a chance to get up.
Oh really?
Okay.
That's good to know.
Oh no!
Oh, now there's three.
Oh god.
I'm in.
Nice, Doki.
Not nice anymore.
Oh no!
How does that one hit not hit him off?
No!
It's up to Ditto!
Wait, no.
Ditto's dead.
Okay.
Nice.
Hey guys, I think...
Look, I got my one.
Guys, I got my one.
What were you guys doing?
Who got their ones?
I got my five.
You did not get five.
Only two people fucking died in that entire time.
Yeah, I got five.
You did not get five.
You missed my clutch guardian angel save.
No, that was amazing.
Yeah, but you guys died regardless so does it matter?
Listen, what's more important in life?
Saving someone or killing someone?
That's what I thought.
Well, if that person you're killing is gonna end up fucking going to jail anyway for committing murder, then like killing them is a better deal.
You heard it here.
Doki thinks murder is justifiable.
Yeah, if you're murdering another murderer.
If you're gonna stop and cry, if that person is gonna commit multiple murders and you murdered them before they commit multiple murders, then it's justifiable.
It's like coming back in time.
What if that person was about to murder someone who murdered their child?
Well, what if that child grows up to commit more murders and he was like a time traveler?
Uh oh.
Yeah, I think that sounds logic.
Yeah, that makes sense.
You heard it here.
Doki said it's fine to murder children so they don't become evil.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm saying that child ends up going out to becoming a murderer.
Therefore, there will be no problems.
I'm saying if that murderer was a time traveler who knows the future of what that child is going to do.
It's like if you have the power to time travel, we travel back in time.
Your logic is flawed.
You know how your logic is flawed?
Because if there's time travel, it would already happen by now.
Yeah, because it's a paradox.
What if they created a multiverse so that it drifts off to a separate multiverse?
Multiverse!
I love Marvel!
Yeah.
Yo, someone pull the trigger.
I'm going in deep.
Go, go in.
Oh, no, I'm stuck.
I'm pulling.
Go in.
Yeah.
Okay, then we have to...
Oh, they're here!
They're here!
That fucking bomb!
We gotta take them out!
No!
Hey, they're chucking!
Oh, no!
What happened?
All of our stuff got destroyed.
No!
We gotta make sure we got...
I'm bringing the bombs over!
Just keep putting bombs in.
Yeah.
Get the bombs!
Oh my god!
Throw them off!
No!
I made one bomb go off.
I dragged it down!
I dragged it down with me!
You're gonna die with me!
You're gonna die with me if it's the last thing I do!
Goodbye!
Oh my god.
I spawned back into my own base.
Go on the other side!
Get the bomb!
Go do it!
Yeah!
I'm back.
I'm bringing the bomb over.
Oh, sweet, sweet, sweet.
That's me.
Take them over!
No!
Oh no.
He jumped over.
He's over.
I got crushed.
Put the bombs in!
I'm coming!
Oh, they sent two people over.
It's okay.
I'm back.
Ow!
That's me, Ditto.
That's me!
Ditto, that's me!
Kill me!
Okay.
Hey, we're not doing too good.
I got the bomb over.
Take the bomb and do it!
Come in!
Oh,
he caught me with the bomb!
What
did you guys do?
Uh, the bombs went off.
Guys, are we?
I think we're out.
I think we're out, guys.
Guys, we're not last.
We got one win.
Oh!
I can't feed my kid!
No!
Poki's gonna kill my child!
Your future child.
Look, we're not last because we won our one game.
Yeah, we got that very first game and we got high egos and then we... failed miserably the rest of the time.
One more game!
We did the best we could!
We could.
For every winner there has to be a loser.
Starting map three!
Oh wait!
One to one.
Not GG's?
Yes.
No.
One to one.
Wait.
Yeah.
Don't eat me!
Question mark?
These guys on the enemy team don't know what the fuck's going on.
I'm like Rumpelstiltskin.
It's okay.
It's all about the friends we made along the way.
Yeah.
Right guys?
I'm so excited now in the future if someone asks me to play I could just say, oh yeah, no, we won some games on Twitch Rivals and I can lie even more about my resume.
I'm so excited.
I got to play with the legendary Pussy Slayer.
Yeah, yeah.
That's done.
Done here.
I got my Warp Scepter during all this.
That's a dub.
It's alright.
It's okay.
In the end everybody gets money.
Guys.
Everybody wins.
Everybody gets money and that's what it's all about.
Everybody wins something.
That's right.
That's all that matters.
Let's kick this out.
Exactly guys.
Exactly.
Well, GG is everybody.
What a journey.
GG.
We're the first one out.
Okay, GG.
No, no, no, no.
There's been a team that lost every game and that's not our team.
Yeah, but they still they were in the quarter finals.
That's not our team.
There was a team that lost every game.
But that wasn't us.
Okay, that's all that matters.
That's all that matters.
GG's everybody.
GG's.
GG guys.
Good luck with the rest of your day guys.
See you next time.
Bye bye.
Alright, I had a great time.
I had a fun time with everyone.
It was honestly a huge blast playing with this team.
And we had a fun time with this team as well.
There's been some...
I feel like on Twitch things just get much more cursed in general.
It's just the Twitch life.
Anyway guys.
It's okay.
We won our first game.
That's all that matters.
It's all about the adventures.
And the fun we had.
I know.
Hey guys.
We do have another stream tonight everybody.
Look, I was not the dead weight.
I did some clutch shit.
That's all I'm saying.
I pulled off my ones.
I did my ones.
Okay.
I defended.
I defended so well during the trebuchet moment.
I fucking defended it so hard during the trebuchet.
And like sent bombs over and everything.
Like bro, come on.
I went full.
I fucking beat up the goalie.
And I scored like four goals.
Like...
All you did is punch the goalie.
And that...
And I did my one.
I did my one.
Okay.
And I sent the bombs over.
What they did with the bombs was their job.
Like I sent the bombs over.
They had to finish the job.
I did my 50% of the work.
I was sending bombs out.
I did...
Okay.
That is not true, Sherpo.
At best, I was the 80% at that point.
Look.
All I'm saying was that...
No, no, no, no, no.
Were you really the 90% in that one game we won?
Huh, Sherpo?
Were you the 90% on that one game we won?
Where was the defending?
That was Brie's job.
Brie was the defender.
I was fucking sending bombs over.
I was carrying the bombs over.
And then I...
I sent it over.
And then Brie had to do the defense for the other bombs.
Mr. Lane Robbins was the carry.
What is this?
You're supposed to be my echo chamber.
What the fuck is this?
Anyway, guys.
I had a great time with everybody.
I had a great time with my team.
For those who are new here...
Also, thank you for the week away.
But I'm just about to end it today.
Because we just finished Twitch Rivals.
But anyway, guys.
If you're new here, I usually stream on the YouTubes.
So please check me out.
Doki Bird YouTube.
And that's where I usually stream.
I actually have a stream tonight.
But I'll be speaking Chinese tonight on YouTube with Hiro.
And she's fluent and I'm not.
She actually knows how to read and write.
I don't know either.
Anyway, if you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch.
And if you want to know when I stream on Twitch, I usually tweet out when I'm streaming on Twitch on Twitter.
So please follow me on Twitter.
What else?
Also, Friday, there's going to be a slight change in the schedule on Friday.
I will be playing Marvel Rivals because I actually got invited to the Alpha test.
I knew tweeting that out was a good idea.
But yes, a person who knows the community manager reached out to me and said that they wanted to send me a code to try out Marvel Rivals on Friday.
And they were possibly... I might be like... I don't know what it's called.
Let me read what they said.
They want to make me like one of the official content creators for Marvel Rivals.
I'm not sure yet.
But maybe I'll find out later today because they said they want to give me more details about it.
But yeah.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated, pause to check you out, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And when you stay up from me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.